nous sommes un parti de gouvernement
c'est ce qui nous différencie de tous
les autres il y a ceux qui nous
gouvernent aujourd'hui et qui ont échoué
il y a ceux qui aspirent à gouverner et
qui échoueraient ces gouverner parce que
leur solution sont pires que celles de
Monsieur Mélenchon nous sommes une
droite de gouvernement nous sommes une
droite qui défend la liberté économique
d'une somme une droite qui promeut la
baisse de la fiscalité des charges qui
veut déconstruire la bureaucratie et la
technocratie qui paralyse et qui
entravent les initiatives c'est pour
cela dans le moment que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui celui de cette réforme des
retraites et je veux le dire très
clairement que nous fuirons nous ne
fuirons pas nos responsabilités nous
avons un devoir devant l'Histoire nous
avons le devoir de cohérence par rapport
à ce que nous avons toujours fait
ce chemin de la réforme porté sur les
retraites par François Fillon en 2003
par Nicolas Sarkozy en 2010 par Edouard
Balladur en
1993 par Jacques Chirac Marie-Claire
Ethan a été la secrétaire général
adjoint nous devons être cohérents et
nous devons être responsables par
rapport à l'intérêt du pays la situation
démographique de la France
impose des réformes d'autant plus
difficiles qu'elles n'ont pas été faites
depuis de 10 ans si nous en sommes là
c'est parce que ceux qui nous gouvernent
n'ont pas eu le courage le moment donné
et le moment opportun d'aller sur le
chemin de ces réformes ils ont
procrastiné ils ont attendu ils ont
reporté et naturellement plus son report
plus on attend plus on décale les choix
plus ils sont difficiles et douloureux
donc oui nous serons cohérents